[Music]
our environment for Paso tire
the way my cardio district is home to a
beautiful and diverse natural
environment that suits us on the
mountain to the sea
[Music]
we have protected forest areas wetlands
tussock and grasslands we have many
waterways in which we are working with
Nigeria and Environment Canterbury to
improve the quality of the water we also
have areas especially in the East that
are susceptible to natural hazards such
as flooding our districts our senator
Waimakariri swin 48 ounces concentrates
the majority of residential and business
growth through our existing main
challenge protect and enhance native
flora and fauna investigate innovative
and cost-effective green approaches to
subdivisions and building design such as
solar how to take water quality by
directing growth to areas through the
state system water supplies and
wastewater services and encourage growth
in areas that are not at significant
risk of natural hazards so ordinary let
us know your thoughts and find out more
about the district development strategy
or why my career is ogod seas or India
you